(exciting music)
(gasps)
- We're all gonna die.
(girl screams in other room)
They got her.
- Guys, guys come on, that's not funny.
- It isn't us.
It's really freaking dark isn't it,
like really fucking dark?
- [Glasses Girl] Who forgot
to pay the electric bill,
- [Polka Dot Dress
Girl] Not me I paid gas.
- I pay internet.
- Something.
- What do you pay?
- Maybe, does our Landlord
pay the electric bill?
- Did we forget to actually
sign up to pay the electric?
- Guys,
it's the whole street.
- Oh.
What do we do now?
(whooshes)
(zaps)
(clicking)
- Guys I can't just sit here in the dark.
- Shit my phone died.
- Shit mine fucking died too.
- Mine didn't but I'm at 12%
and we might need it
in case of emergencies.
- [All] Light as a
feather, stiff as a board.
Light as a feather, stiff as a board.
- I don't like this game.
- [Girls] Light as a
feather stiff as a board.
- I don't like this game, stop.
- We're gonna make you levitate.
- So the ice power up stops
the pawn that has the ice token
from being moved for any reason.
Oh come on guys, this is gonna be fun!
- And when she made her
way into the bathroom,
that's when she turned on the light
and found her husband's severed head!
(cries)
- Mmm, okay,
have you ever been in love?
- Oh, yeah, I was very much
in love with my ex boyfriend.
Um, you met him right, Jack?
- Oh yeah he was at that party.
- Yeah.
- He looked like a dick.
(laughs)
- He's actually really nice
guy, we're just very different.
- Oh well that sucks though, I'm sorry.
- Mmm,
thank you.
Oh you.
Truth or dare?
- Truth.
- Have you ever taken a shower?
- Wow,
- Damn.
- Yeah, I took one this
morning with your mother.
(laughs)
- Hey-Yo.
- Cheryl was very kind and gentle
and loved a good scrubbing.
- Ew.
- Um Bridget, your turn.
- Um,
dare.
- Of course you pick dare.
Pick truth!
- I want dare.
- We don't know anything about your life.
- You know me.
- What about England what was
your life in England like?
- There's not much to tell really.
- That's fine she can pick
dare if she wants too.
- Of course, I'm sorry.
Okay, dare, what's her dare?
- Uh, I just wanna sit out.
I'm sorry.
- Oh boo, come on.
- I just don't know.
- You can't sit out.
- It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Elliot your turn.
Let's go.
- Dare.
- You two kiss.
- That's,
- You're lame.
- No.
- I'm so lame?
- That is lame as hell.
- No that seems like a bad idea.
- Yeah.
- It's a great idea.
They're friends, they don't
like each other like that.
- Okay, then why don't you guys kiss?
- Yeah.
- Alright.
- No.
Maybe we should have you
two kiss first though.
That's like, that seems.
- Oh my god this is so stupid, okay.
- Let's just do it, let's
just get this over with.
- Yeah.
- Not in front of me.
- There you go.
- Ah.
- Okay, I'm gonna go get
the wine from my room.
- Oh that was something
I didn't want to see.
- And that's bad so I
will be getting wine also.
- Okay.
(laughs)
- Maybe you should cool it on the whiskey.
What, what is that?
Okay, hi.
Oh we're hugging.
(sighs)
Okay.
- You are so sweet to me.
- [Girl In Polka Dot Dress] Here it is.
- You found it.
- Yes.
- We shouldn't.
- Yeah.
- Aren't cuddles just the best?
- Yup.
- It's just hard.
- You were the one who
said you didn't want this.
- Yeah, I know.
- We live together now so we can't.
- I mean we could.
- That is an awful idea.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
We should go back out.
- [Polka Dot Dress Girl]
What's going on here?
- I um,
I, I don't know, she was cold and I,
she did this, I didn't do it.
(laughs)
- Right.
- Oh, okay.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna go to bed.
- Yeah bed sounds good.
- Yeah, let's do that.
- I think that we should do that.
(doors shut)
(knocks)
- [Bridget] I live here too.
- [Glasses Girl] Sorry, I'm sorry.
- [Bridget] Yup, mmhmm, yup.
(playful music)
(whooshes)